Oh am i live oh hi hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to crash
bandicoot I know some of you aren't here
yet but that's because people are
watching in the past and people were
coming in live but I'm gonna be playing
this game hi hello hi guys how's it goin
welcome to the stream and welcome to
what is probably going to be an
explosive rage fest unlike any other
that you've ever seen in your life so
hello hi welcome welcome one and all yes
this is live and I can see you in I can
see your comments right over there so
we're gonna be getting into this and I'm
not gonna be waiting too long I'm just
gonna let people know that I'm currently
live right now Oh boink and boo boo ski
all right so happy fourth of July
happy America day or murica day yes hi
hello yeah I know
so we're gonna be doing this right so
Crash Bandicoot is a game from a lot of
people's childhood but I actually never
played it I I didn't have the
opportunity this was in the era of
gaming where we couldn't afford the
consoles so I think it wasn't crash on
the ps1 it wasn't even on the ps2 like I
had a ps2 way late in the game but then
I wasn't even able to get that so I had
to make do with what I got
so anyway hi yes hello hello hello I
know I know I know we got to get going
here we got a lot of stuff to do and not
a lot of time to do it so I want to try
to get through this game as much as I
possibly can
and I'm gonna be doing the original just
because that seems to be the one that
people have a lot of trouble with so I
have no idea how this is gonna go it's
gonna go like a lot of the rage
platformers of the yonder days of old
where there was no hope and no life and
nothing to hold on to in the darkest
dream so here we go I'm gonna go right
into it and I don't know the story I
don't know the nothing I know next to
nothing about this game all I know is
that everyone was asking me to play it
because it was obscenely difficult but
I mean looking at it it didn't seem that
bad Oh
okay we're gonna plot is this
anyway go to get animals to be your
generals did you say prepare the female
if you're like turning them into
monsters or whatever have you or
whatever is that why are they wearing
clothes in the first place he's taking
animals and then giving them
intelligence or I don't even know I have
no idea yeah game is quiet
all right I'll turn it up a bit let's
see how that does I'll do it in little
little spits and Bert's because I have
no idea how loud is loud because again
when I'm live-streaming I can't hear it
I live at that a little better hopefully
yeah so I know that you can spin do a
lot of okay all right then it's on Rails
I guess well thanks to jump Square it's
been crying over inventory it's not much
of an inventory but I'll go for it yeah
yeah geez yeah this was this was in the
era of gaming where I was kind of away
from it like back when this came out I
think I was still playing on the Super
Nintendo why
and I know you're supposed to gather
these so I'm not completely ignorant to
it little louder little louder all right
fine a little bit louder little louder
that's what you get hopefully that's
good enough and if that's not good
enough then I don't know I can't help
you I mean so far it doesn't seem so bad
it seems that that weird and momentum
that all these platformers often do
hello they're giving me free lives like
the candy so I guess I'm gonna die a lot
right on top of that grab the damn thing
what is this what do they do is this
invulnerability is just like a Mario
star okay here we go
[Music]
all right well which way do I go left I
mean again I haven't gotten to the
really obscene obstacles the work damn I
don't know what that is we're supposed
to get 39 out of 49 something's but I
don't know what it was Oh boxes oh can I
go back what happens if I go back ah
what was that I don't know what happened
but I think I took damage oh I don't
think I want to go back maybe it's not
worth it is that good volume is that
good and everyone good everyone seems to
be good I'm gonna just assume that
everyone's good
yeah which you okay I missed ten boxes
well nothing a little more brain damage
isn't gonna fix geez louder no I'm not
gonna do it louder everyone seems to be
fine with it so I'm gonna stick with
that one the wumpa islands these are the
islands of WAMP alright fine then sure
I'm down with that
oh oh it's like Yoshi's Island Oh way
back in the day I love you she's dialing
that Evo she's island on a stream way
back when oh man
yeah you guys are good happy fourth of
July everybody
yes I can see you this is live this
isn't just a normal video I can actually
see you yeah it's some people are good
some people say louder alright I'll
crank it just just the tiniest bit
louder has it hasn't actually been
getting any louder from when you heard
it before because I'm assuming prick me
hard poor animals why am I just walking
in here as a tornado of death I'm not
doing so well because I think I'm sick
well alright then oh my shoes whatever
blew me up down there so don't hit that
good is it good is it too loud now the
too loud I have no idea whatever volume
is good I saw so I'm gonna trust that
one that's all I'm gonna do I got no
other way of going about things
I just put my
I think I went on top of the box but I
don't think I was supposed to do that
got some apples do anyway okay seems to
be a lot of death in this jungle why am
I even here what is the point of all
this okay
alright we're fine then hold that up
there I saw nevermind not gonna see it
because I'm freaking jumped on that I
saw something up there okay alrighty
then here we go that is pretty lady yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay Oh turn it down a
little bit okay alright whatever I'm
just gonna leave it the way it is yeah I
forgot I just got in this mini mood and
decided to hit everything and it
suddenly blew up in my face
Oh Oh
where am I going oh I keep saying oh but
I have no idea what I'm talking about
here crow beer I don't know what that
means
well okay hello lady crank down the
volume just a little bit because I'd
rather it be moderate than overwhelming
so yeah okay ship Podolski alright I
mean I really don't know the whoa I
really don't know the point of this it
seems not bad so far
god damnit with the freaking boxes how
am I supposed to be able to get all of
them I went through the level I think
alright whatever it is what it is and it
is what if we're just gonna get smashed
in the brain a few more times
someone gazing said mark happy fourth of
July and here's a hint boxes named TNT
jump on them
oh really I'm supposed to do oh okay
alright then oh yeah why do you hate the
wumpa fruit volume is good by the way
love your channel happy fourth okay
Dumbo jump on the TNT boxes and graded
boxes you were killing me hey I'm new to
this game you let me be new because I'm
about to get angry probably at some
point if it's actually it's difficult
which I don't think it will but uh we're
gonna see all right yeah I know jump on
the boxes I know I know I get it I know
I know I know the apple crates they uh
they uh they do their thing where they
you got a jump on them yeah you gotta do
that big to get all that these the wumpa
fruit is that we move ha hold X to
bounce higher okay ah
I'm just wondering where it's all gonna
go wrong hello okay okay when you're
gonna get hard
boink help okay that doesn't help me can
I get on ah I want to get on top of that
I want to get on it uh I was on it oh
just like that man
I'm not even a mush of blood just like
complete and utter straight squeezed my
soul out of my body put myself through a
juicer my soul came out that's that's me
that's my right let's not do that again
cuz that was stupid point that's why
they give you an extra life in that one
because they're like ooh all right so I
just got to go through it easy
monkey dead turtle dead flower dead and
everything's dead you have to go back
and get them it's a bunch of baloney as
if I'm gonna need the lives anyway I got
enough wherewithal to be able to I got
enough wherewithal
I got enough work to be able to beat
this sumbitch anyway there's some over
here no that would've been cool if there
was though that would've been really
cool something tells me I'm not gonna
like these jumping puzzles am i oh yeah
turtle dead monkey oh you live life but
you're dead now oops
alright then I'm starting to see where
maybe this is gonna be a son of a
turtle dead
oh look back from the grave dead dad Oh
nas itself dad alright ah why are they
spiky dildos yes thank you lady that's
gonna help me later i oh hai okay
ah one of the natives I guess you go
with the rest of the animals then
this is so weird I'm walking into this
place I mean all he's doing is trying to
defend his homeland but she's straight
up murdering everybody cuz I mean I'm
it's not even like I'm just no I'm
knocking them off and they're falling
boy oh this is gonna be real fun there's
gonna be good okay did I get them all
did I get them all right don't worry
have fun oh well Oh No there was an X's
around here good walking through the
whole place yeah man all right whatever
but I can see how this is gonna start to
be a son of a because it's like I
want to be the guy guy Dan like which
which I always wanted to get back into I
only played it once like we long ago
but I'm gonna try this more and more all
right but in all honesty not that bad
not that bad I don't know how long it
takes to beat the first game and I don't
know if I have enough time today to do
it but happy fourth of July everybody
yes oh
the wrong way now oh this is messing
with my brain I'm gonna be able to deal
with this oh yeah
Indiana jones-style huh well bring it on
you bastard I don't like this bowl I
don't like this no I'm supposed to stop
brick I keep forgetting I know my luck
I'm gonna need those when I walk up hey
yeah okay oh yeah okay I don't like that
I don't like that at all I don't like
that get girls I got you looking out for
the boxes now cuz I want to win I want
to impress people with my gaming skills
that's what I got right gaming skills
that that's all me 100% oh my god how's
that rock out as nimble and moves as I
do hope those are unmarked graves of all
the animals I just tossed off the
mountain can we get matpat with a game
theory about where these bodies end up
and if it's eventually the dead bodies
of all the animals that I send to their
deaths I got a diamond I get all the
boxes I think I got all the boxes I
wouldn't have seen yes ah shovel that
pulled that right out of my ass did I
and that's no lie that pulled right out
of my ass because you saw the reach in
and the struggle to pull it back out
geez yeah oh happy fourth of July
heylia Candela magic Cartman oh thank
you all so much
back to the wampa Islands
all right here we go
any minute now what the heck is that
there's someone playing music in my
apartment hang out I've got a mystery to
discover here I'll be right back give me
one second
yeah I'm back now mystery solved chica
hit play on a music video that I had
pull up it was gorillas just like grills
was just playing in the other ribbon I'm
like heck
someone here no one's here
just Chico being a goof who need that it
seems easy this seems downright Pleasant
oh can I sing the bare necessities while
I'm going down this river it's like a
one-hit thing right
one-hit chaos all the way I need those
oh well that's a load of baloney
that's all big ol lower baloney you go
by the key to these platforms is always
patience and that's the thing that I
remember first when I approached him so
good golly
all right you bastard okay we're fine no
need to panic help me do P there's
something else up here 2.0 what you
chinstrap no bandicoot's can't swim they
just straight-up drown not even like not
even slow like fine we're fine I don't
know why there's giant piranha plants in
the middle of the jungle
they're just sitting with mouths gape
okay that one is time that one is time
to the others not time that one time
okay I get it I get your
color-coordinated here you
think even snack on me no way no way
Jose and what's with this lady is that
this lady's was prepped for my arrival
I'm assuming so why why are you dressed
are you impressed by my box breaking
skills I bet you are
don't lie oh don't lie you are so
impressed I'm gonna start to hate this
game morning I already hate it with like
the the finicky controls the momentum
based movement or is it momentum based
or is this one actually not momentum
based and I'm just used to momentum
based do any of you even care what I'm
talking about no how can she slap
how can she slap huh is
there something with like these ghostly
platforms that lead to more
distant happy the July I miss
before I don't know I know what that all
about but it's not good but either way I
gotta press on and hope for the best
oh is that guy mr. wampa then is that
tiki wampum man I've no idea yeah July
diddly-doo yeah oh boy hey should I save
should I save yeah whatever I got out of
save it's all good
who needs to save pappu pappu what does
that even what is it body blows don't
hurt him whoa what am I gonna do - Babu
Babu
oh hi Babu Babu are you doing Papa Papa
you're good oh sorry I don't even know
how I got in this Hut oh I get it all
right well this is easy
okay cut that butt crack can I just got
to get that on camera the whole time I'm
only gonna hit him on his butt crack
comes around oh no I missed the timing
on the crack that's not primo crack
territory he's dead would you would have
landed facedown
it's just facedown oh man the guy's
already there oh he's breathing I guess
so he's still alive
he's lucky one of the few inhabitants
that I didn't send off to their doom
silly good yeah I don't have any
memories from this one I really don't
like because um when it comes to
memories in gaming like it's all Super
Nintendo yeah those are my those are my
more cherished memories what is this
thing
ah oh hi hello you want her to join
you're sure what okay sure I'll go with
that one I don't know why what
difference does it make does she have
like different qualities or something
like your jump is different because I
just got used to the one that I have now
how am I gonna even enjoy the one that
you're gonna give me now I have no idea
vanish Fox love your vids don't forget
to jump on boxes this game loves to let
you smash stuff yeah I've noticed that
it also loves to let you die so that's
always good yeah oh yeah this is it's
weird about this game because this is
one of those remix remakes is that
people actually seem to embrace and
maybe because there was a lot of value
out of it like it remade it though some
seem to be different so far but it added
a lot of value by remaking three games
in one instead of just the one which I
guess is good but my gamer instincts are
too good to be forwarded by the likes of
you swam buddy I'm not in no oopsy
poopsy sorry
I'm not in Venerable now god damn it
same damn alright tries again I'm not
gonna be in venerable apparently
although I would have liked that there's
a Ledge right there going that's about
to blow cuz I bounced up against the
side of it doesn't mean I got crushed
wonder I got this though
Oh in the wrists it's all in the wrists
of her also why are they sending a
Chinese would why did why did crash this
was like oh hey a kid you want to go
through this perilous dungeon I'll just
I'll just join you when it's safer oh
damn it everyone's mad at me now oh did
I get them all yeah I did all right
hello wait Coco's time machine does that
mean it's this girl that girl does this
girl that girl I have no idea whoopee
boink deep dude oh my god oh okay yeah
ba ba ba ba ba ba think you're going
alright this one cool seems good so far
what just the one does that mean there
was another one over there whatever I
don't care
hey yeah they gotta be the same right
okay time machine yeah who knows the
plot we're so so incredibly irrelevant
all right let's do this
what do you got for me okay I'm just
expecting the blind alleges now Oh was
that gonna move on me it jiggles I don't
like it jiggling what are you I don't
want to go to your bonuses own oh that
sounds terrible
oh all right come on you you think you
got me you think you got me nah nah nah
who's first level that have actually
lost more lives than I've gotten I think
just beating that child with boxes 24
this is a load of there's a lot
of ball I am better than that I swear
but then again that might not be true
all the things that I say could also be
lies excuse me a thirsty Big Brother
d'lai go set off some fireworks or
something all right keep going Coco is
crashes sister oh okay so they're not
the same person maybe I don't know I
have no idea why is Coco here I don't
understand the family dynamics here
understand the animal people and the
people people and why war okay we're
just gonna go with this a bit normal
all right riding a hog into the wild
woods no one by me
boink bonk OH watch out for the dildos
piggy piggy oh they seem to be
everywhere this is decoration
why was this a good choice you see a hog
the first thing you do is jump on get up
I thought it's gonna be like a you know
pork you not me these geysers damn
it ow I landed right on that dildo like
back first okay fine you time the
bastard Oh missed me man that's gonna be
impossible ya prick I am NOT ready for
this okay
yeah bang on the bongo drum okay
everything fine everything's fine I know
what I'm doing I think I know
Oh oh my god it's your brother or mother
or father oh no it's your cousin your
cousin 1po Oh No who's that aunt Lou
well damn
that one was too much for the pig it's
the emotional burden alright fine now
that you've sealed yourself against the
losses that you've just experienced
let's try to go back and face face the
inevitable here Mr piggy some
psychological damage to this poor pig
right now can you don't just you know
just go through that and then leave
unscathed like that is that's a that's a
mess you up kind of thing that's a mess
you up kind of thing to see all of your
friends and family on spit-roast
rotating around a fire and you gotta try
to get them walk while a Bandicoot is on
your back saying kiddie the off
like it's a little bit of an emotional
drama there yeah Thank You Cody
testicular oh no you're mentioning that
but oh happy birthday happy birthday out
there happy birthday oh man this is
funny it's funny though it's got that
charm you know when platformers were
simpler like what's the objective break
boxes sure good enough what's the other
objective
revenge no escape I don't know I'm gonna
go back to grass here people crashes all
about cuz uh Coco's fine and all but
crash is really the reason everybody's
here right yeah hello hi hi everybody
how's it going
happy fourth of July this is my special
celebration it is super cool yeah so I
get an extra life every time I get a
hundred ok I mean it's the same
principle as coins right I mean that's
what it always was right
excuse me while I just yeah okay all
right that's fine
I love goodbye hello goodbye hello
goodbye hello monkey goodbye you can't
roll away from your fate death is coming
[Applause]
the hang of it so I don't think death is
gonna be approaching too soon that's
gonna give me some day isn't it I just
want to murder you stop letting me
bounce on your TomTom and just walk into
my flying fists oh that's an extra
bouncy
goosh goosh ah no okay
you sack of car no how am I supposed to
get oh I see how this is gonna be
I see now I see nothing for who you for
who you truly are
dude okay I was like ah little did I
know level ah
little did I know of douche why
excuse you excuse you
excuse you excuse you alright then we're
just gonna accept that as reality
instead of the world that I live in
we're laws obey physics why didn't you
die why didn't you die why didn't you
why didn't you die you know you should
have died I spun I spawned and usually
when I do a spinny dance move everyone
around me dies
so I thought that was just what it was
and then you didn't do that so let's try
this again shall we
okay boy and now you're dead huh good
job rectifying your previous mistake oh
my god I'm not that was my fault
completely my fault
oh my fault
let's see why they stock me up with all
these lives then but I guess that'd kill
you wait for that
foosh oh what's this you're dead okay
that seems like you shouldn't that seems
like you shouldn't make that no not
today
I hate that how did that happen I spun
up there there was an explosion in the
sky like a firework and then Oh
oh no you do not get dildo can't jump on
official Fury no one can escape the
visib Yuri because I have no idea what
I'm doing
hello hi bonus bonus already getting
stressful
I don't like it oh okay was that all
them septic alright then yeah I don't
even need this Apple but I'm going back
for it because I think I'll need it
thank you
Hey bye bye then I'm stressed already
but it's not that bad it's not that bad
just the precise precise with imprecise
controls but it's not as bad as some
games where some games have our required
precision and have very non precise
controls I can't even think of a name of
one but you guys know what I'm talking
about
like Octodad or some crap like that I
guess I guess octave come on I'm jumping
I'm giant jumping I am very clearly
bouncing to go higher take back what I
said about the precise controls this
game handles like a 300-pound hog oh
yeah I guess if you just hold it down
what I was doing wrong
I was uh letting go each time you just
gotta hold it down is it Rick there
could be well if I just start off with
that I'm not gonna do too good am i no
I'm not oh well all right
live and learn and then get loves and
jumped on all right this is where it's
gonna give me huh
I did it again I'm an oh I'm
gonna get you so I got a jump real far
is a jump further than that next time
oh wait for fire oh come on it wasn't
even close to me
oh I don't like you okay not gonna do it
this time I'm probably gonna need these
apples
shoot boink shoot boink okay no I was
looking forward I wasn't looking where
my feet was he's thinking me this Dennis
I can get a steady stream of lives but I
think I'm gonna run out of all of them
for the end of this
don't like that what's very clearly on
the thing I was right on there the wink
get you I was I was on the thing it was
on the damn thing
I shouldn't be rushing Oh what are you
giving me well I just used it up so I
guess it wasn't even important oh boy oh
boy is this is this where everyone else
has trouble I bet it is
unless I'm just an idiot and not able to
give this to them stupid did I mention
I'm an idiot
I'm on it there we go Oh God why wasn't
moving forward I swear oh I hate you I
already hate you game how do you like
that record yeah I got all the
checkpoints here bah bah bah bah even
daddy boot time to go that was the wrong
time to go
yay
[Laughter]
I switched through the directional pads
this actually makes my life a lot easier
[Applause]
alright okay is that close to the end my
at the end you okay
you get rekt oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh okay
can't panic now yeah oh are you supposed
to do that
that's impossible oh come on I'm not
even near it I'm married
oh don't give me that
waiting patiently daddy for 200 not
gonna give me live this time too much
mercy on you
[Applause]
okay like that one yes okay Oh Oh the
immunity got me the immunity got me Oh
thankfully I got that oh oh thank you
thank you I didn't need them thank you
it knew it knew this game freakin knew
it knew how my brain all the webcam
froze Frick is it back there we go ha
damn it
where did that freeze where did that
freeze I always want to know don't even
tell me don't even talk to me
don't talk to me or my son ever again
did that just freeze or did it has it
been frozen for like forever
oh my god I died everybody was I'd die
oh how I died okay just very recently
okay
all right cool maybe I don't know who
cares would it matter
can I just freeze in a permanent face of
like rage just screaming blood shooting
out of my head where am I going now
excuse you yeah there's a logical
fallacy here I don't see how you're
getting from I was climbing up a tower
and suddenly I'm at a different Island
there seems to be a bit of a bit of a
stretch going on here alright fine then
I'll play your game you roll
hi buddy
what are you even doing there what are
you doing there one bow oh you love me
why I don't even know why what is this
for
why is this here so you can fall off of
it Oh
directional pad not good on this one
gonna stick with the non directional
take that thank you
oh you bastard that's how you're gonna
beat me you're gonna get it later once I
the cash and chicks I don't like that
nope
but a cindy-lou who token get wreck gets
rolled oh my god you son of an ass I
rolled on your face and you're gonna
treat me like that
you buddy just walk into my fists that's
all I can manage right now I'm very very
low-energy putting all my energy into my
brain right now you rolling back you
rolling back yeah that's what you get oh
no I don't like that don't like that
either oh my get any of this actually I
hate we gonna take it out of here please
that'd be nice what does that go
[Music]
what oh that's why they were give you I
don't get you at all don't get you why
do I even want this I don't think I want
this why do I want this why do I gotta
go back what did that do
well that was my way back
I'm just gonna ignore that cuz who needs
it honestly who do I need it the answer
is no I do not
don't need it don't need any of this oh
don't drown just drown drown in air I
got em all I think there's secrets in
this that I don't know no where am I I
don't even know where I am anymore
am I really is this really where I am
this is really am i all the way back
here really really I would love to see
someone trying to speed
oh I kicked it out of the way I'll just
drown in the river then because oh
that's what happened to it you can blast
it out of the way I could yeah that's my
I thought I could sworn that I got him
all stupid piece of Garbo wonderful new
house boop boop boop okay you gotta get
there we go cuz that's how that works
that makes sense to me
that would have been my opportunity but
I'm cautious right now very cautious I
mean got survival strategy is that any
way is randomly whenever you feel the
need to it you just thrust your mouth
upwards out into the air and hope you
catch something cuz it can't be actually
antagonistic towards me right they just
do that all the time don't know where I
am don't know where I am don't know
where I am we're fine
smashing BIOS smash these boxes Bluto
okay
blasters boxes there we go I
feel better about my life maybe if I
could get a checkpoint I'd feel even
better because I'm a long way from home
right now ie give me a goddamn
checkpoint that'd be really cool
oh no no you stay back here you oh
I was right at the end when I fell and
died
oh I only missed two boxes those are
probably the boxes that it spawned in in
the bonus area what does it even matter
if you get all the boxes
does it matter this is a collectible
I don't like collectible
hmm I don't collect anything
well I'm the best obviously not I am NOT
the best at this game okay
you run I detect some logical
Ripper Roo Roo Roo Roo legas Ripper Roo
and why do I care
direct attacks don't hurt him oh then
I'll just fall over and die the Ripper
Roo I'm gonna swim up a waterfall like
okay hi okay oh hi oh are you going
buddy hey okay Oh yep I drowned cool
that's good I need the big TNT that's
what I need
alright you follow a pattern or
something oh come on with this okay I'm
using the directional pad because you
only go yeah
well can't I've work too early on that
one all right you know what I'm just
gonna go for it okay why is this one
getting me you know why is this one
getting me that's the question of the
day now oh no well this is going to be
the biggest pain in the douche I've ever
known isn't it
let me just study his pattern cuz it's a
pattern right ah I get it I get it
come on I was using the directional bad
I get it I get it I get it I think I get
it
okay come on boom there we go
he's got to have a new pattern or
something right yep he does oh boy I
don't know what it is oh boy okay I
don't think that's gonna get him no it's
not gonna get I see what he's doing
though no that's not gonna get him
goddamn it no it's not gonna get down
there in time maybe this new ye heat go
good get him get him get him get him get
him come on get this one get him no no
damn it man come on we're gonna
be back by now
right come on get him oh come on no
that's definitely not gonna get him from
damage keep I keep miss time again
it's like after he just leaves they're
like go down quickly enough no God cuz
that moves the way I forgot
but maybe this month whoa that got him
oh no oh no oh no how did that not kill
me oh no no
okay now that's gonna get them too late
no oh god I was standing around being a
douche douche being a douche hi Zanna
are you gonna be all right I'm going
back to the joystick because I hate life
okay goes there here then I can get this
one and then when he comes back he's
definitely gonna be hit by that one
right yeah and then it's just a diamond
pattern I think is what I saw
maybe oh boy move move Oh God okay nah
oh that's a little too late but oh maybe
not it's close you you whole ass
oh no that timings way off
yeah that's gonna get it that's gonna
get it that's gonna get yeah that's
going get all right I got I got your
number got your number I got it got your
number we by the time he gets back
around right no no God not quite but
that one I bet is gonna get it yes yes
oh yeah Ripper goodbye how y'all
doing
you having a good fourth of July I am
man I cannot believe that took that long
to be able to get through that should
never have taken that long to be able to
get through I don't know why and I don't
know how but I'm okay
so i'ma carry on with this because I'm
still going for this I'm still going for
it I am still doing great I'm still sane
I love this I love it it's so good right
it is ha ha ha Oh play crash 2 & 3
let me get through one first and we'll
see what happens later I don't know how
to get that I don't know what's in there
all right cool got that I don't know why
too big boob date shoo
hey watch it there big rusty excuse well
I meant to jump on that but I guess too
late did I just kick away all my goddamn
lives it was like 14 lives there at
least I got that one okay nevermind
that's just a test jump god I need to
jump on those things I'm so too bad my
Saddam non-existent box Oh like
that
get rekt I know you're trying to take a
nap but I don't have any patience for
you I got places to be and think do okay
that's weird but okay ah yes of course
let me jump up there and claim that
prize oh ah ah beat your system breath
panic for no reason a lot
okay got it cool off we go hey we're
doing great what are you jumping I
should have jumped on you but I got hit
[Music]
yes the moving tongue platforms just
what I wanted to deal with today who
built this stuff civilization capable of
building this constantly moving
platforms it's like the same it's like
the same people that built all the
and Donkey Kong how floating barrels
that just magically shoot monkeys and
are perfectly calibrated nonetheless
perfectly calibrated to be able to
there's some secret that unlocked or am
I just falling for I'm falling for no
reason I was assuming that there was
some secret that that unlocked like I
was was before you know how remember
that when that did that thing yeah I
remember that - those were good times
when you actually made sense all right I
got this guy's I know you're all very
worried and concerned but trust me when
I say I okay I went down that was great
I meant to do
don't like that ha he'll I don't even
know how to get those things I do not
know how do I get back here how do I get
back there is there a way how about the
big archway over here excuse you don't
even come near me don't come near me or
my son anymore ever again
I guess I could have gotten that in this
session but I just didn't feel like it
you know how it is you know how it do
you know how I be you know uh explain
yourself
explain yourself funky bridge explain
yourself I'm all ears for how that works
all right excuse me what are you gonna
do nothing you can't fall over and die
excuse you
Gooch well I don't like the way this is
at all okay this this this actually I
can handle this is okay does this makes
sense to me I mean not really
I still hate it oh I see
boop boop boop boop beep boop don't ok
I'm gonna jump on you okay everything's
cool everything is awesome
Oh got this all right baby coming back I
got the bonus got the frickin bonus
happy fourth of July everybody
oh this is gonna wait oh I don't like
this I don't like that at all I don't I
don't like that at all
Oh like that I don't like that
Oh like that much at all oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god I don't know how
many are left
what boat fruit bag oh come on oh I can
try it again
can I go back oh okay that's that's a
little better
oh man that this one's about to be a son
of a I couldn't tell
like No
okay I gotta get on top of it nope can't
do that so I guess I me then ah no
yes gooo I don't know how I didn't know
how many were left game you're freaking
impossible
[Music]
yeah but never never never never never
never never maybe I'll just clear three
four five one two three four
oh no dude oh god I'm out down eat every
one two three four five one two three
four five one two three four five one
two
oh no how did you not break you come on
it's so easy what about me what are you
counting Wampus when you could go the
wumpy right way
[Music]
okay if I got pushed off in what world
can you push me off
one two three four five one two three
four five two three four five oh boy
one two three four five oh my god oh no
oh no I got you
[Music]
I don't understand you game I would like
to
what are you doing hey buddy how's it
going over there Oh
I want those I don't know why I'm gonna
get you see that did you see that I got
you
I'm that right Oh put it back here
is there anything back here all right
fine then hey uh where are you bark okay
alrighty then manage that didn't I
oh you know those probably did they
probably opened the pathway at the very
beginning of the level but I'm not gonna
drop down try to find it
yeah no way I know how oh yeah
sumon oh yeah crash is about to get the
beat out of them his brains are
gonna oh my god
yeah face down ass up that's the way to
do a crash that's the way you take those
boxes I'm good I'm good everybody happy
4th of July
happy 4th of July everything's good is
it is it gonna get worse that's my
biggest concern right now is that it's
gonna get worse as time goes on it's
only gonna get worse and I'm gonna be
even less happy than I ever have been
missing boxes follow the trail of wampa
fruit
how about no how about you go shove your
wumpa fruit into your urethra go take a
long walk off a short bridge how about
you do that no I'm not bitter I'm not
bitter at all it gets knocked away of
life again hi hello you're gonna get one
sorry about that just the way life works
I'd like to think there's just people in
those pillars
yes hi that poor snake just he was going
over the ball and then knocked into
oblivion as it should be
snake bastard Jafar look-alike here all
right well don't know what you're
running away from and why I'm going
towards this but here we go like these
crushing backs is there maybe they're
just out for a run you know they're just
a hi spider okay I can't get up there
anymore because of doing the goddamn
directional pads like an a-hole I can do
that okay is there anything that I can't
absolutely decimate with my spinning
fists and also what am I going well that
was an adventure I sure I'm glad I did
that
oh look upgraded fire okay my eyes were
closed my control is broken I don't know
what's going on I don't know what that
was it's that's what
that was it's like it behooves me to
switch randomly between the directional
pads or the joystick er get rekt you
pieces of guy I don't care what I'm
leaving behind it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what I do it's what I
leave behind that's important guys do
you remember that do you remember when I
said that yeah look a right
hit the only thing I didn't want
to hit oh you can't even spell Prague
I'm not okay in case you're wondering am
i okay don't do well under pressure I
don't do well I know you get all your
shits and giggles ah ha ha hee Matt oh
ho ho
where's my feelings pretty concern my
emotions okay bye then you spider
oh god this is why I don't do rage
I don't know ah kayo good thing I moved
huh ain't it hello hi I'm paying
attention now
boink no no no no Australian for a
second let go of these goddamn penis
pillars everything in this game is
excessively phallic shape did you guys
notice that I don't know if you guys
have a keen trained eye for the phallic
nature in life I for one do I am an
expert at detecting phallic things
anywhere I go you gotta stop spinning
like that because I'm just losing out on
all the that I need
[Music]
I got this better get worried play
worried
what's the matter fix your face eh my
fault okay
give me that frickin chicken okay got
that I just gotta keep going
finish this bad boy out good rekt care
what you think don't care what you do
I've got your number you're gonna get
screwed oh no I'm sorry to myself I
didn't know I was singing myself a song
there didn't understand it I didn't
understand it at all hi Megan I didn't
understand it at all oh that's a new way
to die
oh that's creative and interesting oh
I'm sure I'm in love with that oh ah
completely forgot that the birds birds
you know the leather birds were a
frickin threat forgot about that
these coalface ask alright go down now I
go now I go where that go I don't care
if they're boxes over there affected too
good for it I off this way
okay you guys doing good out there you
guys doing good I'm glad you do good I'm
doing great
all good I do Wayne Gretzky good I knew
I wasn't gonna make that I knew I knew I
wasn't gonna make that nine lives
oh how the mighty have fallen
oh how the mighty have fallen okay no I
did it again
is that gonna come back at my bone thank
you thank you I was about to jump into
the abyss oh oh man I'm going to you I
forgot that that's all right girl
oh come on move forth no oh it wasn't a
way to keep going it would have caught
me Oh
Dixon ah my face eat it they never heard
of me
don't let it go to waste No
all right doing great don't care about
that oh boy good gonna catch me I have
faith I was in the wrong place I was in
the wrong place shouldn't I put my faith
in that okay ah stupid bats oh you
stupid rats hate you forgot I forget I
always forget I do anything where I
forget okay bats are incoming apparently
there they are well I should have gone
because now my opportunity is wasted
there we go scooch scooch to my Looch
scooch to my luchador okay
this time don't trust it in faith wait
for my brain can only process so many
things at once that's what my brain can
do wait
alright I guess that would have been
fine there there they are
nope this was a Hut timing but okay
we're good guys we're good if you guys
think I'm sure if you guys think I'm
stressed at all you guys don't know me
and if you don't know me
speed run baby speed run Margot bar I'll
start my new let's play channel alright
just show you guys how great I am at
everything I do don't I do that anyway
it's so great ah the best the
best there ever was were got it nailed
that one
like a peach where am I going guys
where am I going guys Oh am I going
south is that what I'm doing I hope Oh
alright good we're taking on a journey
okay God Oh first try baby baby leg way
better all right I got this oh wait huh
what why do I need to wait on
anything I'm the master of this disaster
oh man look at me go
I'm so cool and calm and collected and
handsome too made it oh you two killed
me right then and there where are those
blonde peas I like this I don't like
this oh God
Oh Oh got it nailed it nailed it in
every way were you guys doubt me you
guys doubt me yeah
doubt this got it there we go
that wasn't so bad everybody happy
everybody okay with life great me too
all right we're gonna carry on happy
fourth of July everybody happy fourth of
July hope you're enjoying your days good
luck on the next what's in the next
level I'm doing great
did you just see what I did try not to
cuss in the last in the next one all
right I'll try to make this
family-friendly Marga bar in this next
one road to nowhere I got a good feeling
about this one when it's named a name
like that you know that it's got quality
and quantity in its mind
it's got great potential in its but oh
man
direct attacks don't hurt these
high-altitude hogs why are their high
altitude all right here we go don't like
this precision I nailed you nailed you
to the wall there's nothing there
alright didn't want to do that but it
did it anyway I'm a rebel baby baby I'm
a rebel you guys watching out there did
you know well yeah I did that because
I'm such a badass I didn't even need to
worry about in the first place why would
I worry oh oh is this gonna be the whole
level the whole level is like this the
whole level is like this oh good alright
well looks like things are about to get
creative up in marklar town you know
I've always thought that I was
emotionally and mature enough to handle
adversity wherever it may eat
I needed that board it's okay I can do
without it I'll do it live baby oh I'll
do it live Oh give me that oh oh
high high altitude Hagen where did you
come from you know I don't like this I
don't like the implication here that I
have too heavy to walk along these
boards but you you
uh-huh I'm something all right you pick
back there to come over here and now let
me show you how I did you've done oh
look at me oh look at me I don't know
what that was all about but oh look at
me boy
I don't know what you're on about I
don't know what you're on about no
precision all the lights up what you
touch me
how about cursed already I have no idea
I like instantly forgot what I was
trying to do in this episode no more
cursing for the longest time nope you
are a lovely human being except you're a
pig I love the way you've done your hair
today I hope you get everything you wish
for in life got that
these are giving me more lives I'm
slowly building up my my supply again
okay Pig you you surprised me there I'm
not gonna lie I have a UH
I got startled you jump scared me well
you didn't need to worry about that
because I just threw myself off the
bridge anyway so whatever you had going
on less important now all right
welp I don't know how that works out but
it did so I guess that's just what I got
to live with all right piggy piggy piggy
let's see you do I'm gonna lose my mind
I'm gonna lose my mind okay piggy piggy
let's go okay big big let's go got it
nailed it I'm the best look at me don't
need to even look Oh what's this waiting
for pigs
that's for chumps I do kind of look like
a chump to you don't answer that
question because I'm afraid of the
honesty a lot of these things don't
matter to me oh I'm a risk taker hey all
right
guys cool see I've gotten better at it
no one's saying anything out there no
one say a goddamn thing do it why I
thought I didn't make so that's why I
let that sight reading this
oh well don't go backwards or else
you'll just immediately go in the hole
what's this baby what's this
you you do you know a thing oh boy one
life left
welp wasted opportunity it all comes
down to this done it all comes down to
this time all comes down to this done
don't mess up I'm not gonna mess up Oh
who'd mess up
who would mess up this face not me I say
to you not me not me I say to you I'm
good this a bag full of Dreams all right
you come back here oh yes I've got a
lovely bunch of coconuts filled Leedy
your they are being a son of a douche
let's do this again shall we let's just
pretend like that didn't happen
everybody wipe your memories get out
your men in black things we're gonna go
for it again
there's one thing that markiplier is no
quitter spell my name my neighbor buddy
how do you spell my name come up with
something I have no idea how I spell my
name I'm doing oh yeah that's what I
wanted to start this off on the right
foot
nailed it well didn't even care about
that hey you hog oh right in my heart I
think I'm in love
come here you Pig I love how I can see
your your buttholes you turn around oh
no wait that's this your tail sorry
must have been my imagination screw that
and I'm gonna wait bye wait I mean I'm
gonna go anyway because again stupid but
that is what I do you know I'm only
stupid when I'm not smart that I hope
you guys understand that that's just
some thing about staying alive staying
alive
[Music]
didn't do a damn thing to me I don't
remember where my check point is either
oh good back here in the same
nondescript location as everything else
is so I'll never be able to actually
tell where I am great or how much
progress I mean cuz also like the
logistics of this I can teleport across
an ocean and just you know do whatever I
want to do in that department but when
it comes to actually being over here on
ice bridge I got across this Pacific
bridge
it's one full of emotions and dreams but
you know whatever life isn't exactly
what it seems it's a good rhyme there's
another checkpoint gonna blast through
everybody shut up everybody shut up
everybody shut up I'm concentrating I'm
in the flow I'm in the thick of it
who spoke with one of you what what I
needed that I know always wanted Jeff
I'm looking right at you Jeff Steve
Meghan cut it out
what's weird all the lines go should I
go back to the beginning in farm lives
this is D case down no no no I don't
need it I don't need it I don't need it
and you need me I don't need you you
need me
that's how let's go you understand what
I'm saying
probably now okay anyway carry on what's
this nothing what's this Oh nailed it
I know what I'm not I know what I'm
about oh oh oh
got that right were you impressed hog
were you impressed oh yeah running away
from your emotions come back here and
face your lover all right
oh great just what I wanted more apples
for my life lives go I thought they were
used to give me lives here now that's
just a bunch of stupid apples I don't
know I could turn an apple into an egg
for life filling the holes caused by
these giant spikes Apple I know it's not
an apple I know it's a One Bowl fruit or
whatever the crap it is I don't care
right now they're apples oh yeah yeah
yes Leigh Leigh this is what I like that
wasn't what I like I don't know how to
dip I don't know how to make it any
simpler that wasn't what I like it
wasn't Oh almost messed up there that
wouldn't be like me messing up plus I'm
missing apples who do that oh not me are
you talking about who oh who are you
okay okay
got it who are you whoo whoo whoo whoo
give me that is that a turtle that's
something I can kill I'll come back for
you
hey Dora I'll come back for you those
did I just fall oh oh
are you kidding me oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god you sack of ass
I was right there I was there I was
right there how did I fall oh no what
happened
are you kidding me eat every nip oh I
have to shove it in you Oh cut my hair
off I don't care
alright I'm okay I'm fine cool calm
collected the cursed yet I'd like to
think that all right
and I forgot about something let me fix
it sitting here I'm louder than I
thought I'd be so I'm gonna tone some
down here okay so now hopefully I won't
explode people's eardrums well I don't
think I'm gonna have to scream again
dudes and dudettes if you know me you
know I faked my reaction you know that
right this is all an act
yeah you know everyone knows I'm super
cool what are you talking about everyone
knows this what
it's like right there the checkpoint was
right there
gimme those I need them I know okay
you're fine it's fine there go some
apples that I desperately needed Oh long
jump decision like you've never seen
before this time I'm gonna do it I can't
believe it
I was right there checkpoint another day
another dollar another day another
dollar another day another dollar
another day another dollar yeah give me
that immunity it doesn't help when I
fall off into the abyss no does a cheeky
man oh no it doesn't you got no answer
to that one that's cuz you're stunned
silence says it all alright this one's
the one because I'm gonna make it
exactly where I need to go you know I
might as well just let that thing hit me
oh you didn't hit me that time were you
scared oh he's scared Oh get out here
give me that okay
apparently there's a jump how and why
why endear oh I don't have a te this
time oh no oh no oh no oh no yeah you're
all running away running away running
away running away running away
jump on it
there we go I'm not
how do I help humbled I get down there
okay I didn't need to get down there I
suppose it all comes down to this
okay I kicked one of those lives away
didn't I don't need it I can finish this
I can finish this I got it I got one
life just die you would have hit me you
would have hit me I needed that title I
needed it judge you emotionally it's
heartbreaking
heartbreak is heartbreak heart-wrenching
heart palpitating hardened squeezing oh
good you're on the edge you see doctor
[Music]
but it's okay because I must have it
down by now
you guys know how good at games I am if
I ever mentioned the tale of how is born
born of small island in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean out I hate life Oh
missed me didn't ya now I got your
number right there
oh I didn't think that was gonna make it
but then again what I think largely
doesn't matter in this universe Oh feel
the love tonight know what I didn't want
I was actively trying to avoid that
outcome fine I don't eat it it's gonna
go sprint to the finish who needs extra
lives when you got this much skill when
you got this much vim and vigor inside
your soul I'm just pulsating with skill
nailed it I'm on the roll don't stop me
now oh nobody better stop me I know you
guys out there be frickin stop me you
got this I get that
don't matter whatever it's all good nail
you to the wall to the wall window oh
Oh nailed it didn't even need to
think about it good even know what my
name is something so who are you any of
us oh yeah
because you fell down a mountain doesn't
mean that my emotions weren't hurt
that's what's more important here right
am I right people am i right hell yeah I
did it hell yeah
oh you can walk on the ropes
can't think about that right now
gotta keep my hands in the key gotta
keep my hand again back in the game you
can walk on the roads Oh huh it's a
funny joke that's a funny joke
pepper goofy to me that wasn't true was
it funny joke funny joke funny joke you
guys are so funny that's what I love
about this community so loving and
endearing and hilarious to coming up
with ridiculous boos oh man
Oh cuz if that were true is if that were
true and I just wasted my back doing
those jumps oh that were true all right
he'll be my channel prolly leave my
channel move to some island somewhere
kind of live it all out the life of a
hermit maybe climb to the top of
mountains you know
I feel like that I'm so warning people
do is go up on that mountain old man
markiplier is up there and it's like
yeah you look up here me I'm I would
kill the next person I scream just over
that so funny joke guys funny I just
I'll take those thank you yes cool
alright alright I really don't know what
the point of those things are
oh boy we're still going we're still
going still going it's been real close
getting real close oh no it's getting
real close II nailed it
well that was a fun one let it be known
you helped some of us get through the
day well thank you so much professor
derp I really do appreciate this Oh
funny fluff you love the videos very
entertaining well I'm glad my pain can
bring somebody joy I don't know how much
further I got into in this adventure but
we're gonna keep going with it oh I feel
good I feel joy inside my heart I feel a
lot of warmth right in here might be my
heart just stopping out of pure anger
but I'd like to think it's love the love
I feel from you guys is that lip
that looks final over there although I
don't know what the end objective here
am I trying to get back to the
laboratory so I can beat up the
scientist that was there is that kind of
the whole objective of this whole thing
I have no idea yeah yeah the elaine ian
mark you can jump on the ropes happy
fourth thank you thank you for that you
are the light of my life
where's your sleep oh you're you're the
lining of my underwear hmm you're just
they're always so comforting so close
that's fire
jump right into that cool whatever I
meant to do that it's all good it's all
good it's all good okay here we go guys
again
monkey bris still don't understand you
Danu haha you were faster you're a quick
winning job that's disappointing some
but you know I'm okay with this I accept
you for who you are where am I
there I am bow let me know over well no
wonder everyone's been to stop me I'm
stealing all their foods these people
are not gonna make it through the winter
okay quick shot here we go Oh am I gonna
make that why Lisa gave me the extra
boost I needed
fun this is a fun game guys yeah fun
this game ones but it doesn't matter
because I'm gonna persevere so it's okay
okay here we go still into the fire Oh
time man still perfectly that's how you
do in the speedrunning I don't even need
those just to show how I just like to
lose because it lets you guys know I'm
not perfect that's the only reason I
mean I am perfect you know you know I
[Music]
don't know it's all good
alright checkpoint I had to concentrate
let's go for it any danger
get rekt bats
welcome to the party I jump on your head
no I don't know how I survived good guys
life is good did you guys know that have
you ever heard about this thing called
life and how great it is
oh no that's not sacrifice me to the
gods
[Music]
got it nailed it nailed it got it okay
how to concentrate again but you know
these points of concentration you know
that I'm just a chatterbox I sometimes
have moments where even I need to go and
boy that just makes it seem ominous oh
no no no Jimmy no
here we go I don't know why this is
vexing you don't know you don't don't do
that to me oh I'm out of oh I'm okay I'm
okay but I lost my immunity because the
bat just came out of fat hell and
flew in my hair and messed up my shoe
who dare hit the mark EMU mark you're
such a good person
at least the fire was there to catch me
that time
[Music]
oh we're doing it we're doing it we're
doing it hype is hype mode engage type
mode engage everybody get hyped mode
everybody hype everybody hi I think
we're almost there
there's got to be the end of it right
it's gonna be the end hi boat oh come on
there's more gotta be Oh didn't know
that was gonna happen
there's gotta be the last fish because
it was the last guys don't mind if I run
back here okay Oh almost jumped off to
my oblivion I always like that that was
that's my chance they saw my tapping
skills and they were like photo blur he
gets really mad sometimes what they all
say about me oh hi
[Music]
nope right there got it you were too
quick for me you were too quick you
thought that you were slow no I thought
that you were slow and then you were too
pays all right come on showdown get
wreck baby mama fees right into that
fire I walked right in I walked right in
right in right into me watch I better
not run out of life because if I have
the game over this whole level again I'm
going to strap my eyes your eyes
back babies back babies and go and get
newer to me ain't gonna get none to me I
changed my mind
how do you explain your actions what do
you have to say for yourself
mark big dumb goofy guys okay
[Music]
we're no Batson coming in I was so
scared
[Music]
I'm okay everything is fine
happy fourth of July everyone out there
watch this speedrun so sick in the
skills Department that I don't know I'm
not gonna be impatient son I'm not gonna
take my time because I'm so good at this
okay remember how I was talking about
how human I am wink get rekt oh yeah
that's for me
well I'm I want to bring that back yeah
cuz now that I've shown you how human
and fragile my psyche is I want to show
you what it truly means to be the expert
gamer that I is I don't know if you guys
know but I'm pretty dang
it had games and this uh-huh
it's some of this nope this is not where
I wanna be okay I guess it worked out
again for me why do I not wait for that
why do I not wait for that I don't wait
for that why it's as simple as mechanics
it just you should wait for the pillars
to stop pushing their giant pillar dicks
and then you go when you're not about to
be impaled by a giant pillar dick like
it couldn't be simpler
and I don't do it I don't do it
why that's been fat and then I go cuz
that's how humans do things when they
need to problem still alright you go in
you shy you go back in there you
remember how you were all hypemode and I
totally called the wrong timing on the
hypemode well start getting hype again
because oh boy and about to get all
kinds of pipe up into a queue or if you
arrive to me right give me right oh
thank you for shielding my bum bum from
those hot flame things
got an extra life that's always handy
and wait to lose that one hypemode hyper
gauge oh no way hypemode isn't here
hi Moniz later I'm Otis after the
checkpoint which I'm gonna nail well no
oh my god no there was so much space to
stand on and I shredded it blood
pressure ain't gonna handle this
not much
I love jumping puzzles thought this was
your town none the noona it monkey town
the people it flyer town population why
why are you not going on it why are you
nothing
am I crazy there what the hell hype mode
is to fight fight mode to know why why
bye bye stop why do you do that no I'm
not gonna what in the world is happening
this is the easiest thing why am i
falling there should be no reason it's
just jump up on a friggin a platform
there was that so hard
apparently yes okay nail this on the
first try cuz I'm about I'm a box ass
I'm a bad No
what was that
oh hello me here how did I get to this
point again don't understand
jump
grab that get to the cheeky pointy
what's in the mouth that's cool
okay I don't like this at all
everybody pray right there that's what I
need and I need to quickly go to the
other thing not there there okay type
mode engage
not there here oh okay oh why am i
trying to widen widen a trip all I had
to do was wait all I had to do was wait
only ended it was waiting then I did
something so was gonna do something that
it always goes wrong for me yes
here got another life I need them so
badly not there not there here I'm not
going for that one I didn't like the way
that one was set up that one rubbed me
the wrong way
nah I don't like that one either I think
I'm on the wrong platform but I'm just
scared to go to another one yeah this
this one is more agreeable for me will
give me with all my patience
look at me with all my waiting waiting
this hard though okay just nothing
there's nothing there's a whole lot of
oh look at that that's enforced a no
extra lipo good i'ma spin in here
because I don't know if there's any
enemies got that what don't know why
it's gonna wait patient
patience really really really more
scared sorry I got spooked good
there's no jump on this one it's just
walk right oh that's nice
ah lovely day today
[Music]
type mode engaged
I actually feel like this might be the
one now whereas the last one was hype
mode for a little premature on the hype
mode
this one's hype mode I know I can feel
it oh I hate you I hate that and I hate
you oh I love you cookie
I'll give you kisses all over wherever
you want good boy another trick point
that's always a good sign fine so many
times he caught me over and over why did
I panic why did I panic why did I panic
I better get up here where did I hit a
checkpoint did I maybe it took mercy on
me
I remember being up here No
[Music]
all right and with that the stream is
coming to a close happy fourth of July
everybody
my god subscribe for more of this
amazing a rage-inducing content let me
know if you want more of this I can't
decide if I'm gonna Oh boss I can do one
more boss
I can do one more I can do this boss
this is like the end of this island so I
gotta do the boss right I gotta do the
boss right
he likes to flex whenever he has an
audience oh well I'm gonna be observing
oh god alright nice push there buddy boo
I'm not sure what you want from a see
good oh I can go forward I forgot about
that I didn't go forward I didn't what I
didn't I was using the directional pads
what the heck
okay I don't know do I need to throw it
back bring it back maybe maybe that was
it oh that look son spinnable oh okay
here in my mouth
come on me okay this doesn't seem so bad
okay hair in my mouth oh you don't have
an audience you meet throne Roxy it's
like you aren't you dude
oh I didn't think about the minecarts No
go gotcha okay one more I got this you
think I don't got this don't look good
all right okay all right cool
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching uh let me know if you want more
of this I might actually do more this is
because oh man I can see the appeal how
much more do I have to go is this the
last island or something I have no idea
I don't know if there are how many
islands there are I've never played this
before I had a good time
so let me know what you thought let me
know anything I don't know if I'm gonna
post this full video or if I'm gonna
make a compilation out of it like a rage
compilation like the Mario maker
compilation but this is fun so let me
know what you want if it's a stream
whatever videos let's play I don't care
I'll do it something great about doing
it live though so thank you everybody so
much for watching subscribe if you want
more like favourite I don't
know I don't care do whatever you want
to do chair yeah shares are a little
Louis month so thank you again i'ma
off over this way
that's my outdoor right god I'm still
throw P I'm sorry I'm still grumpy so
great everyone's like wanting a rage
compilation I'll probably make a rage
compilation oh I think that'd be fun so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye guys bye
the KC night deaf boy bye bye guys